we have reprogrammed our lives to be
remote and so we are stuck in patterns
that are really difficult to get out of
i actually
i don't know if i'm gonna get cancelled
for this but
i think that um
michael hobart the ceo and co-founder of
straba with over 76 million athletes you
track your activities turn those
activities into a post that's when the
strava magic happens if you want to be
as good as you possibly can be you have
to strive to be the best but can you be
okay also with not actually achieving
the goal of being at the top of
everybody win or lose that's the feeling
you're looking for
how are you doing in your personal life
my wife was diagnosed with a terminal
illness in september of 2013. i think i
prepared a lot for how
to live my life
caring for her i wasn't prepared for how
to live my life when she was gone
[Music]
i had to
not rediscover who i am i had to define
who i am that doesn't happen overnight
if what you do every day is put a little
effort into being kind to the people who
are important to you in your life and
the complete strangers then that's where
you're going to find the meaning
so without further ado
i'm stephen bartlett and this is the
diary of a ceo usa edition i hope
nobody's listening but if you are
then please keep this to yourself
[Music]
michael
i tend to believe that
people have i know i eventually
developed it but i tend to believe that
people have some kind of hypothesis
as to what factors or experiences from
their earliest years
shaped them most significantly
into the person they are today do you
have a hypothesis like that
i think i have several starting with
how my family
felt
to me being the youngest of of the five
kids in my family
felt like it was pulled apart by
geography
uh between sweden and the united states
at an early age my sisters stayed behind
when my family moved back to the states
when i was five years old
and
i had this uh dream to reunite us in
some way how could we how could we be
one family again um now my sisters were
older they were choosing to it was the
normal
maybe a few years early what from what
you'd say normally would have happened
anyway then deciding just
where do they want to live who are they
as people
and but me i was i was this
five-year-old and i was uh i was sad to
to lose my my sisters my uh i had my
brother with me and
um when you think about one of the most
important things in your life it's the
relationships you have with people
um now i'm not necessarily an outgoing
person myself so i don't that's not
where this is this hypothesis has led me
but it has led me to the idea of
connection deep connection with people
you care about is super important for
how you
live your life and the choices you make
and what you prioritize
so that was that's the one that's one
theory and then there's one other one
which is i think
growing up
going through high school coming tonight
first of all coming united states not
speaking english at the age of five and
learning it all you know from television
and getting thrust into school and you
have this
this feeling like you don't belong you
don't fit in uh that just that kept you
know for many people i think it keeps
going and you don't have that great
sense of belonging until later maybe
until your teenage years you're later
even into your 20s
but throughout all that time of
searching and looking for something like
what i kept believing is that
there's something inside
me
a potential that needs to get realized
and
i don't just think that about me now i
think that about every single human
being on this planet and um
the
aspect of what it means to realize
someone's potential your own potential
and then
create the opportunity for the people
around you to realize their potential
that drives me that is something that
i've i feel like has been a
constant in
everything i've done since i've been
about 25 years old that moment when
you're you're growing up and you've
you've
parted ways with your siblings seems to
be one of the first seeds that led to
the success of
your later businesses because it was i
mean
in hindsight i guess we all do this but
you i guess it highlighted the
importance of connection and community
as you said
when was the next seed planted because i
kind of think about that with like great
business ideas and i saw that in your
story that there's these moments
these key moments which introduce you to
like the idea of community and then to
the idea of sport and competition when
was the next chronological seed
um
yeah so coming out of that um
like high school feeling like i know
[Music]
i've i've got some
amount of intellect i don't really
understand like what if i'm gonna use it
um i don't feel like i was that you know
call it like high school wasn't where i
peaked i don't think anyone should peak
by the way in high school like that's a
lousy time to be at your like the
pinnacle of your life you want to peak
later than that so getting into harvard
going to a good school that that seemed
like that would be it but it wasn't that
wasn't it for me it was actually walking
into the boathouse
never having rode before and finding
this group of people who also were
trying to figure out where what's this
where is their place at this institution
that
in some ways it's like well you got into
there so is aren't you kind of done it's
like actually no now you're
you're scared because you don't know if
you measure up you don't under have any
understanding of where you stand will
you make it there
but finding that going into the
boathouse you're like hard work and what
is this boot house this is the house
yeah for the rowing team
it wasn't that i went in there thinking
i'm gonna i'm gonna conquer this i'm
gonna be uh one of the best rowers
that this school has seen
when i went in there but within a few
weeks i was like that was my goal i was
going to be the best like that was
somehow it wasn't there wasn't anything
else except he just turned on inside me
and i was i was hooked by that that
experience
because i found my place i think that
was the key is i'd found a group of
people
i'd found this vibe this energy it was
the part of the day i looked forward to
was the part i felt so good about
the rest of my life because i was there
in that experience
i was motivated by the desire to be as
good as i can possibly be at this thing
and i don't think i'd experienced that
feeling before in my life
i was really compelled by the use of the
word best it made me start thinking
about
the idea of competition and
um i think i sat here a couple of days
ago with simon sinek talking about this
like the role that competition and
wanting to be number one plays is it
toxic
is it uh a healthy motivator because i'm
filled with that anyway we went bowling
last night with the team
i was very quiet until i knew that i was
gonna win
you know what i mean i'm a deeply
competitive person it motivates me it
drives me and i've wondered if that's a
deficiency of my character or if it's a
healthy thing what have you learned
about that yeah i think it can lead to
challenges both at the personal level
and then you know in a in a group what i
found at the in the crew team was that
we couldn't be the best team if each of
us individually wasn't trying to be the
best but we always knew that you don't
win a boat a boat race by yourself you
win it with
um seven other rowers and a coxswain
you have to think like a team but you
have to think like like an individual
who wants to be the best at what you can
be
another way to think about it is like if
you want to be as good as you possibly
can be you have to strive to be the best
um but can you be okay also
with
not actually achieving the goal of being
the top of everybody but being as good
as you know you got reached that point
of you you could not have given more
that's what you're that's where i get
the satisfactions i know
at the end of that race you know i'm
thinking of the race of my freshman year
where we won the championship and we
came from you know a boat length back we
had lost to that team in a previous race
and that feeling that went through
my body and i believe everyone's body in
that boat halfway through the race we
said we're not giving up
and we just rode them down and at the
end of that it wasn't like like i'm the
best it was like we did something that
we didn't think was possible we created
a new capacity
and so then all of a sudden you know
maybe some spaces opened up with what
you thought you were capable of and what
you could be and you you try it you go
back at it again you you train again for
for reaching that point where you said
you did everything you possibly could
and
win or lose that's the feeling you're
looking for i think when you when it's
positive in your life and
i've been in those places where it can
be really destructive too um it changes
your relationships with other people
you start to actually hate the thing
you're doing
because you're striving for the wrong
you're striving for some outcome that
maybe is not the right outcome um what
experience are you talking about
training for races where you're by the
time you're on the starting line you
just don't even want to do it anymore
that was often the feeling i had by the
time
you know a uh a big race came around
where i was just like i'm so done with
this i just want to
just not not be
not be here right now
um these things should be additive to
your life it should be something that
you that makes you
better in other ways besides just
stronger physically probably a sign that
you just you have lost
the reason why you're doing it the why
behind the work
when i was reading about strava's
work values
i read about this
abc's
thing and the b in that was about
balance which is what you're talking
about there
is that in part why you put the b there
in terms of the the culture and the the
office and the
professional culture you're trying to
create with strava is that why the b is
so important there balance
balance is elusive and the counterpoint
we have another one of the c's is
commitment
so i talk about that a lot that
these things seem like they're at odds
with each other if you have balance how
can you also be 100 committed to the
goal of building the best company we can
build doing the most we can do for our
athlete community
and i say yes that is the struggle in
life is to both have
balance and be committed to something
it's incredibly challenging and
to hold both concepts in your in your
heart and in your head
is is the work that is actually why
they're there they're there to remind us
um
if we only have one balance we won't we
won't do as much we won't we won't
strive for as much as we can be if we
only have commitment we will burn out we
will we will get to that place where we
don't love the work we do anymore and we
will question why we're here
so it's by putting them together that
that my co-founder and i felt we had the
best chance at achieving that long-term
commitment with balance and it's a
struggle it is you're not there's no
recipe here there's no you know playbook
that tells you how to do it um and each
person does have to work at it
on their own on their own is it their
responsibility to to work work at it i i
sometimes struggle with this as an
employer which is what role do i play in
because i know the role i play in
driving commitment
right it's very obvious you set
ambitious goals you set tight timelines
you create a good prize and a worthwhile
you know carrot at the end of
accomplishing the goal that drives
commitment if you have the right people
and you have camaraderie and all those
things that you said but then in terms
of telling people to
encouraging them to have
balance in their life
what role can i play as an employer what
role do you think you should play um
if you hire people who respond really
well to
those
those motivators that that lead to their
commitment um i think you also have to
look at it from how long do you want
them to be
there to do the work to be working at
that level
and i think you can structure teams in
different ways you can you can roll
through
you know people in the sense of that
they may only
contribute for a couple of years or a
year and and that's that's if that's the
structure
and many companies in silicon valley
operate this way which is
two years that the
on the team is is a pretty standard
length and then you move on uh
and you recommit somewhere else
we are trying to build something
different at strava we're trying to
build the 100 year brand the company
that will
last longer than i will be there
it will still be here
after many of the people who have been
investors in the company have exited the
company it's
it is uh something that we hope will
withstand the test of time and in that
setting
i think it's much more important to
think about these you need some people
who are going to be there for
much longer than that one or two years
that's where balance comes in yes it's
easy to say
you don't want people to burn out but if
it's only that you don't want them to
get that tired that sick of their job
that their quote unquote burned out
you've probably lost some level of
productivity for quite a while before
that so
we strive
for
a different kind of relationship with
our team uh
it is a challenge also as a leader to
make sure we're still performance
oriented we we still want that that
sense that we have we have to bring our
a-game we cannot be satisfied with
past success or
be complacent there's plenty of
competition out there all sorts of new
uh new technologies that are coming
uh into the into the four today new ways
of uh building communities new ways of
motivating people we have to stay
competitive and so that is my job as a
leader i have a leadership team that
helps me with this it's not just my job
but
it is it is ensuring that we are taking
care of our people but also expecting
that they're going to climb the mountain
with us
the way that you're building that
company and what you're aiming to to do
to create a
a long-term
long-withstanding business
goes against the
narrative especially in silicon valley
where the objective is to like raise
money before you're profitable
sell the thing or go public and move on
to the next thing
clearly there's experience behind your
desire to pursue a longer term strategy
where you're not just you know
investing all your money in user growth
getting a gazillion users and then
exiting
i suspect it's because of your other
business the one that came before strava
am i right and if so why did that teach
you that this longer term approach to
company building is a better path
forward for you as the founder
and for other things
when we started strava we were looking
back at the previous company we had
started and we started talking about
um
creating what is now strava back in 2006
we got together
uh starting on the phone weekly talking
about ideas that we if we're going to
start a company what would it be
eventually we got mark and i my
co-founder mark gainey and i uh decided
we had to get together for a few days
the summer of 2006
and we defined at its core that what we
had experienced in that other company
khana software back in in the late 90s
it was the silicon valley olympics
that's the way a term that you you you
have an idea you raise some capital
you're at you're off to the races and
either you have taken a public or sold
it in four years or it's you know and
that's the gold medal
or
go home because it's that's it um we
didn't want to do that again and a few
reasons why um it wasn't terribly
satisfying at the end of the day
we
kana was a wild ride during a wild time
in the first internet boom
um
a lot of people made a lot of money a
lot of people lost a lot of money um and
so
what in it would we look back on and say
besides the experience itself and what
we learned
what would it be that we would say
to our kids or grandkids like
here this is something we're really
proud that we created we can't even lay
claim to having created if we're only
there for four years and then other
people take it forward is it really ours
um
so we were out on the doorstep you know
literally almost four years to the day
after starting kana
how and why well personal choice in my
case i wanted to go back to teaching i
was i came from academia i was teaching
economics when we started kana i wanted
to go back to academia
mark
the company got to a point where he
brought in another ceo to run it um and
he found that it wasn't his company
anymore he didn't have the role that he
thought he would have on the other side
of that decision
so i don't speak for him but it was like
this sense of like it was a personal
choice for both of us but at the same
time
we look back on it and say
where it goes next is not
not part of us we have to forge a
different path there's got to be an idea
that's worth that much of our investment
and perhaps it's that sense of at that
point in our lives where we were then
late 30s early 40s when we're starting
strava
we were thinking about this could be it
this is it's not like we're we're going
to have that many good ideas in our life
we're not we're not going to have
another opportunity and
to to build this kind of a company at
least
um and so let's make it worth it and
let's let's find something that we're
extremely passionate about
and we used to say things like it
doesn't have to be big it has to be
great it has to have me give meaning to
the people who are our customers and we
define that as like we want to we want
to help people live
a more more a
life of
more full of meaning adventure and fun
we didn't say activity we weren't yet
sure what it was going to do
but it had to have some impact
it can't just be transactional it has to
have an effect on you at the at the core
level of what you value
what decisions you make on a daily basis
and that's where i think
we got our we got to strava and i love
to
go to like the idea behind strava was a
20th century idea we had that idea
coming out of the boathouse when we
graduated from college we had the idea
that we what we experienced there is
something that
is applicable in so many places in our
lives being connected to other people
through sport
is what motivates you to lead a more
active life and makes you a better human
being it helps you live a healthier life
and makes all the rest of your life
better it did that for us when we were
in our 20s
and that's the universal part that we
wanted to tap into when we were starting
to create what became strava was that
it's the context of the people around
you that keeps you motivated it's the
it's the way in which you're connected
through sport to other people that
unites you
um and so we started to explore that
space and
um when you explore and are willing to
talk to people about your ideas
they respond they tell you ideas that
they've had that sound pretty
close to what you're doing even if
they're not
sure
that it's really relevant and so those
conversations in the early days 2008
led to us
actually putting
a team behind this to build a prototype
and and that eventually became the
earliest version of strava in 2009. so
it was really just a set of
conversations that led to what we
actually decided on but it came from
something we had experienced in
in um in college back in in the
in the late 80s and 90s a 20th century
idea
when i think about how you formulated
strava and that early process it's like
exactly what i tell an entrepreneur not
to do in the in the respective
um a lot of time entrepreneurs
you see that they actually just want to
be an entrepreneur so they think [ __ ] it
oh gosh what shall i do
and they look around for a problem to
solve one that isn't in line with any of
their intrinsic like passions and innate
motivations so the minute they encounter
some difficulty the first hurdle in
business which is inevitable they then
fold and they give up because why would
you pursue karen doing something that
you weren't genuinely
um in love with and i guess you know i
guess the process is the thing that i
wouldn't i've never would advise someone
to kind of like
sit down with your mate and think of a
business but i guess the process also
led you just closer towards what did
innately matter to you which was
adventure activity community
even though you did it the other way
around does that make sense yeah
well so uh
i guess i'm drawn to tell this like how
we've originally conceived of
what became what is now strava was
in 1994-95
when i'm a professor at stanford
teaching economics mark is working in
venture capital in palo alto
and there's this thing called the
internet
uh that has just become like a household
word uh before i got to stanford
i think i had sent one email in my life
i had never i didn't know what the
internet was i had no idea when i got to
the department of economics the the
person who managed all the i.t equipment
said i'm going to install a browser on
your computer i had no idea what he was
talking about what's a browser
so
had lived up to that point without the
internet and the internet is introduced
it's a different thing than today with
you know kids growing up with all this
around them
but when it was introduced what mark and
i did was exactly that entrepreneur that
instinct is like
what is this new thing going to do what
problem can it solve what's the what's
the you know and mark wanted to start a
company i was a professor i was going to
be his sounding board he came to my
office because i had an internet
connection and he didn't you know so
what we we cooked up was like well what
are the problems in our own life that we
would want to solve with this new
technology as a starting point because
we didn't know what else where else to
start right
so we we went through a bunch of you
know different ideas of the thing that
we hung on to was like we missed the
crew team we missed that
the bunch of people who were you know
from all different walks of life and
they found their the same
thing that we were passionate about and
we spent a ton of time with them we were
with them hours every day
and we missed that feeling of being
connected to them we missed the
boathouse we missed the feeling of
competition could we recreate that with
this new technology called the internet
could we create the virtual locker room
and so what we were describing to
ourselves was what you see in strava
today is like a place where you could
see other people's workouts
you could see you could talk about you
track your performance over time a
training log all that was we sketched
that out we wrote a business plan
this is 1995 right so
we we're we're not anywhere close to the
stat the founding of strava but
in any means we actually went out and
talked about this idea with
companies that were building websites
and that's that was the earliest
internet companies were the ones that
were building
the websites that other companies would
then
use to become internet companies right
so um and they told us this is a lousy
idea you know like
come on guys can't you do better than
this this is never going to work people
are not going to share personal
information about themselves with
strangers on the internet that's never
going to happen
let's see there's no technology that's
gonna make it easy to get the data in uh
people are gonna be having to fill out
forms and submit them online that's
gonna be really really full of friction
you should you should just put this away
don't don't don't tell anyone about this
idea it's such a bad idea right and they
turned us on to the idea that became
kana software which was something so
mundane boring
built a great company but it was build
systems to help these internet companies
respond to consumer
inbound consumer email customer
support email so we did that we got
turned under that idea why did we pursue
that we weren't passionate about it we
became passionate about it especially
mark you know we just wanted to be
entrepreneurs we wanted to to seize the
moment of this new technology this new
world of the internet we wanted to
create something we were motivated by
the idea that anyone can do this that's
the way it felt
and we tabled the thing we were really
passionate about because
some people told us it was a bad idea
and i thanked them for it because it
probably was a bad idea at the time
it would have failed right
but
where we were in 2007 2008
that idea was still in our back of our
minds that idea came to the front
that's what we went and said now what
has changed well a lot has changed right
right so you have facebook
showing us that people are actually
willing to share
with people that they trust on the
internet
you and before that that i'm sure
facebook wasn't the first to prove that
out but facebook was the first to prove
out that you can build community with
the internet at least in our world
then you have gps as in the things
that's in our pocket all of a sudden
this mobile phone has got a gps chip in
it around to that around that time frame
and it's okay it's not great
and so we're like all those reasons why
we shouldn't have started that company
are now reasons why we should start that
company
and it matches the things we talked
about in that time in veil could we
build something that people would use
every day would they tell their friends
about it would it help them get out and
live a more
a life of more adventure would they
would it be trusted would it be a
trusted brand and we're like hey wait a
minute
the universe is putting this in right in
front of us this is all coming together
and why not
why not this and in some ways we denied
that it could be that easy that this
idea we had had
so many you know more than a decade
earlier could be the thing that we're
now going to go and start a company we
had denied that for a while and tried
these other things first we explored
other places in the very very much the
way that you would say the way
entrepreneurs should do it
and we said no we got to do this this is
the thing we and we didn't and then it
says you know you you meet some people
you talk to about
about your idea with some people and you
see
this has got some legs this other people
have had similar thoughts and
you can get them on board uh the person
we met dave davis kitchell
instrumental in how we got this company
started um he happened to be living in
the same small town i was living in
he was trying to work out technology to
use gps
to compare the time it took him to climb
on his bicycle
up a road by his house
he was just
exploring this because he was curious
and we thought oh that's interesting i
wonder if
i wonder if that could be somehow the
basis of what you could do in this
virtual locker room that we were
building
and that became strava segments that was
the earliest
first conversation about something that
became a fundamental part of what strava
is today
that would never have happened if we
hadn't
just opened up and said we're trying to
build something that will help people
live a more active life
and then davey says well i'm working on
something that helps me that might help
motivate me to be more active i wonder
if it could be relevant to you
um and he's still part of the team today
and strava segments is
is a big part of
what people know about strava
what have you learned then from all
these people who are changing their
lives and exercising on strava about
what motivates us to go from a place of
being sat on the sofa as i was in 2020
in march as that first lockdown rolled
in
to
downloading strava and then um going on
a fitness journey there's something
weird that happened to me which i've
never really understood if i look at the
person i was before that date i was a
repeat failure at fitness like every
year this is going to be the year
everyone knows the story like no this
year is going to be the year then
crashed out that no this year is going
to be the year and then
i think i know what's changed but is
there data to prove
or to suggest what it is that makes
people finally get the bug
the fitness health bug
yeah
great question um
what we see is that people who
you do have to catch on and find
something that keeps you in strava but
the thing that happens to you when you
use when you're when you're part of the
community when you're
when you stay with it is you become more
regular you become become more it's more
frequent that you are active
you may not get faster you might but
that's not actually what we see
you're just more regularly active
consistent even more consistent
and so what is
what is also true is that if you're more
connected to other people and doesn't
have to be a lot of people i think most
the majority of it is you have to be
connected to people you actually care
about on strava that motivate you to be
more more consistent
and so we say people keep people active
people motivate people to be active
and
you may not realize it but your journey
motivated somebody else too
your activities were the source of
motivation for someone else and they
were more active and they added their
activities and that was the motivation
for someone else
so this has a way of exponentially
increasing people's motivation
and i believe we can
change
over time over the next many years
we can help people follow the same
journey you took
more and more regularly so we may have
started in a place which was
more about the performance
aspects of being active how can you get
faster
but we quickly realized it's about it's
about consistency
it's about the experience and that's i
think where we keep people you may come
for the competition you stay
you stay for the community you may come
for wanting to track your workout but
you stay because of the people you you
meet and how they motivate you and how
it feels
am i missing anything then from my
because i'm because i'm just personally
very interested in this the competition
the community i guess striving towards a
goal or a metric sometimes for people
it's improving my running time or
something
um
i guess there's a sense that might be
linked to the sense of like
accomplishment of winning a badge or a
reward or a little bing
you know when i'm on my peloton or when
i'm on start you little something
is there anything else that you you've
seen as a significant motivator for
people to be engaged with their fitness
journey well it's got to make them feel
better
yeah i definitely think there's and we
don't i would say we don't necessarily
attract that very well today how do you
actually feel about yourself now versus
a month ago or two months ago we talk a
lot about your physiological performance
we can show you you're better
um lower heart rate lower resting heart
rate you your your fitness score has
gone up um all sorts of ways in which we
can show progress physiologically but
i'm more interested in joy i mean that's
that's
where we're not good yet at measuring
the meaning and joy we bring to people's
lives we'll get there and i think but
that's a very important part of the
equation is that you feel better and you
want to keep feeling that good
so
if i also look back on where we thought
we were starting was
we were building something that had to
be good enough for the best athletes in
the world to use because we believe they
could motivate
people who were not as
committed to
active life to come on board
i actually don't think that that's that
is motivating but i think
the other stories are even more
motivating stories like yours like
you've dramatically changed how you live
your life
you put activity at the center
and that's incred incredibly motivating
for people that they can see that that's
possible
so i believe it's increased storytelling
is really the key yeah
i think that's that's so being you know
the idea of the gamification yeah we did
that
but where we're leaning more much more
heavily now is telling allowing
the people in our community
to tell their story
and not just of today i went out for
this run yeah that's part of a story but
what does this amount to over time how
do i accomplish my goals what are the
things i'm striving for how do i feel
when i get there
and maybe that's where we can start
measuring the joy a bit bit more
precisely
quick one we bring in eight people a
month to watch these conversations live
here in the studio when we're here in
the uk and when we're in la
if you want to be one of those people
all you've got to do is hit subscribe
i was thinking one of my hypotheses
which i've shared many times but i feel
compelled to ask you
is that my goals were bad my goals were
like
they they were goals and it's funny
because it kind of goes back to your
first company there were goals that
could be completed they were short-term
goals this is when i crashed out and
failed all the time they were like
surface level superficial get a six-pack
four summer
goals and it wasn't until i i mean simon
sinek said where you are in a couple of
days ago one of the things he talks a
lot about is infinite games right
until i started setting goals that were
more infinite like you've done with
strava in trying to create a
long-standing company and those goals
ended up just being about consistency it
was like go to the gym today something i
could never accomplish that was one of
the turning points the other was the
pandemic which is i think it was which
was a i mean i mean i know you saw a
boost in customer position i mean that's
when i joined and i i knew the numbers
but um i think in part it was realizing
that health was fragile
seeing that for the first time in my
young life that health was the
foundation of everything i was doing
i actually want to ask you a question
about the pandemic because you were
talking earlier on about how at the
boathouse you learned that community
and connection and these things are so
unbelievably important one of the things
the pandemic has robbed us of is
community and connection it's put us
behind screens so i was compelled to ask
you like what's strava's take on this
remote working thing right you're cool
you're about community and connection
and
you know that more than anyone yeah it's
been it's been hard for us to find our
way back to how it felt to work together
we were camaraderie is one of our other
seas um
commitment craftsmanship and camaraderie
so camaraderie was important in the it
showed up in a lot of ways
we had
a wednesday workout at lunchtime we'd go
out for runs or there was a group that
walked there was a group that
met
some mornings to go for a ride so the
camaraderie in sport yes there was
camaraderie in we spent a lot of time
working together
and building those relationships it it
felt like a team inside the company and
th that was really difficult to
replicate um virtually
um but something else
has happened uh as a result of pandemic
that i think is a real beautiful outcome
that will lead us back to camaraderie of
a very different kind
we stopped putting location as a
requirement on any job openings
so we hired we've more than doubled the
team over the course of the last year
and a half
and have added people across the united
states in many different countries as
well because if you're if you have the
talent and we're looking for it
you don't have to be in san francisco or
denver which were the two main offices
we had or bristol uk
we've now opened an office in dublin so
we will have physical locations but we
have a
over 150 people today who don't
have any one of our office locations as
their home city
and the beautiful thing in that is
these people all have incredible talent
yes they they were the best people that
we could have possibly attracted for the
position
but they have such different lived
experiences
they bring that to the work they do so
we're learning a ton about what
camarader where it really comes from
you maybe the thing we were creating
was in the old uh in the pre-pandemic
times
was a camaraderie that was built around
a
very limited set of rituals like going
for that wednesday workout
it turns out that a lot of people felt
excluded by that because they weren't
fat they didn't feel fast enough to go
with the crew that was going out for a
run we have to find our ways to
replicate or create something that is is
like that today
but what we have is a much broader set
of stories that people can bring and
tell
about what they did before they join
strava what they're experiencing here
they're coming from all sorts of
different locations
uh so that's that's an aspect of what
camaraderie can we feel when we got
together in san diego in person for a
week at the beginning of march
what came out was
how much we already appreciate each
other even if we've never been together
we've nev most of us had never met in
person
but we we already felt like we knew each
other and
we didn't start with the awkward
hello i'm so and so it was hugs right
away it was this sense of this this is
the team that now is
in the same place
and i want to carry that forward i want
i want that to be like we put coins in
the bank that'll get us for the next six
months or a year
to the next time we get together but we
can we can create that sense of
camaraderie even if we're not sitting in
the same office building or the same
room
uh so that was a that was eye-opening
for me that that that was possible
because of pandemic that we could create
this very
distributed interesting
diverse
workforce team
that felt everyone felt for the most
part felt a sense of belonging what role
does that play the in person stuff
because i because we all here
yeah i mean think it's
of my
my personal team here in this in this uh
studio what role does that play though
and what value does that add because i
don't know i think i i think i have a
real bias towards
being with people and maybe it's i don't
know what it is maybe i don't know
i don't know what it is but i like being
with people and i really struggle on
zoom
i don't feel like it's real yeah me too
no it's so
i think what i what it's what is
possible is
you can be with people but you don't
have to be with them all the time that
you can find the the combination of
um
my colleague brian who's here with me
today he lives in dallas uh in the uh in
uh in the dallas area
and
we have
we we looked at the calendar it turns
out we've actually gotten together in
person now i think you know four out of
the last five weeks because
business need brought us together
yet we've also spent time working in a
virtual setting
so it's i call that putting the coins in
the bank we have enough opportunity
to see each other
in person to get that feeling
that we can be more effective
when we have to work virtually together
and i think we replicate that that's the
model i think that we we can get to it
if we only worked with people who are
geographically proximate we're losing
that opportunity
to work with people with a completely
different set of experiences that they
can bring to what we're trying to build
we're trying to serve athletes
everywhere there are
i think easily over a billion people who
wake up every day wanting to be active
and we want to meet them all
they're in every part of the world and
so that incredible diversity of the
customer that we want to serve
it just moves us that we need to build a
team that tries to match that diversity
and the people on the team
and so if we're not there anywhere you
know we most of our team is still in the
us like as in terms of
the geographic bias we have today
but i think that it's not possible to
build that kind of a company that kind
of a team if you're if you require
everyone to be in the same location all
the time so we give some little on the
location and we get a lot back in terms
of what people can bring the different
experiences they can bring to us so i
guess the conclusive question here is
like what role does
the corporations or do you feel you play
in adding you give community to your
customers but what role do you feel you
play in giving that in like that in
person community
outside of your home out in the wild
to your employees yeah we we pay a lot
of attention to it i think it's
important
for people to do their best work that
they feel a sense of belonging and i
don't think this is just that strava i
think it's true in a lot of places and
sometimes that that is so much easier to
do when you're in person and you're
providing
the breakfast and the the the desk and
that's that that place that this is a i
can feel productive in this space and
yes the colleagues around me are people
with you know incredible talent and like
i'm energized by the by the by the by
the group by the the setting that i'm in
um and i think for many of our team they
really miss that um
during the pandemic they would love it
back to come back but it's really
difficult to bring it back
right now it's it's going to take us
time to work our way back why
there are two reasons i see and i i've
thought a lot about this in the sense of
justin
strava's example one is we have
programmed our lives to be remote
reprogrammed our lives to be remote and
so we are stuck in patterns that are
really difficult to get out of just like
in the beginning of pandemic it was
really difficult to get into that
pattern we were forced to we're not
forced to get out of it now strava's not
forcing people back into the office so
it's difficult with everything from how
you organize your your day maybe you
have
children or other dependents at home you
have to take care of
you have
pets you have um
you have worked worked out a routine
that works really well for working from
home
and so getting people back into the
office is getting over those those
hurdles and frictions and so what do we
do we make it more enticing um
wednesdays we offer lunch um
we are trying to organize wednesday as
the day if you're going to pick one day
a week maybe one day a month make it a
wednesday get people oh this wasn't so
bad i got over the friction that one day
maybe i'll do it again that's just
that's like the mundane reason why it's
why it's hard the second reason i think
is more fundamental is like it is really
difficult to be
halfway
halfway back to work
coordination
of either being all remote or all in the
office is a lot easier
and we're not ready to go all in the
office we'll lose people on our team we
don't want to lose that's that's like
maybe a
too much of a calculating
way to think about it it's more like
that i don't think we'll get the best
work out of the people who we forced to
come back in and they stay on the team
um and that just may that that is what
will take more time and more of a sense
of
a sense of security
that this is going to be a good
experience i'm not going to number one
just my health is not going to suffer
the health of the people i love around
me won't suffer so we're not there yet
maybe in terms of from a medical or
scientific basis yet
but i think it's more important it
doesn't really matter what the sign says
if what you feel is i don't feel secure
and safe when i go to the office that's
what i i think is going to be much
harder to overcome
and that's the part where coordination
just makes it really difficult to
replicate if you don't have everyone to
say yeah i'm i work from the office or
during working from home
you lose you lose all those things are
true and we we lot we had that great
sense of disconnection
uh the days of endless video meetings
and
um
trying to do whatever you could to get
that sense of energy you get by being
around another human being um
it was a struggle
did you find in that in that period you
lost employees so
from my perspective with my company we
had about 700 people around the world
one of our big usps as we thought was
community you know that's what we that's
one of our the reasons why you'd come
and work at our company social chain was
community the culture in the office and
all of those things we offered
flexibility so people generally decided
what days they worked etc but the minute
the pandemic rolled in and everyone had
to stay at home in their boxer shorts in
their one bed studio apartment it felt
like people then started to make the
decision about where they wanted to work
based on well
if i'm going to be in my box of shorts
looking at the screen anyway i might as
well get paid more to do it
and we we saw a little it was the first
time in our history where we saw people
just leaving for and we asked why
they're leaving the girl more money
before then it didn't matter
and i was wondering and this is part of
the reason why i think i have a real
bias towards the office can kind of be
like open about what i do in my
companies is
at the moment we actually had a group
session the other day where people said
we talked about the days but the moment
there's two days a week where
we we all want to come we come in right
and in between that like whatever and if
you can't make money like the days then
because you've got something going on
fine but that's when we all try and
really be the present because we want
that synchronous collaborative all that
wonderful stuff
and taking a hard line on it i'll be
honest i think has
helped i speak to so many founders and
companies who are trapped in this limbo
of can't force them back
trying to insert trying to make the
office a nicer place but people aren't
coming back and i i actually i don't
know if i'm gonna get cancelled for this
but i think that um there's risk in not
setting a hard line and having clarity
and saying listen if you don't want to
work here
there's other places to work but here's
how we do it
and we're choosing to do this not this
way not because the ceo is an egotist
and wants to control people but when we
reverse engineer our objective as a
company back from whatever it is we
believe that the best way to achieve our
goal as a team and that's what we are is
by having moments where we're together
as well
and so that's my stance in it not
popular all the time no i but i agree
with you that it it provides clarity for
people they don't have to make a choice
they're it they may be unhappy with the
decision but they say at least it
removes my requirement that i
have to think about it and decide each
time on my own is this the day go in or
other people doing it too
you have coordinated people for
you've done the work of coordinating
them and i think
that's the way we used to operate
we used to have
no we don't work from home we work at
the office that's that's our policy
only under rare situations would we say
that it that's okay to work from home
um so
what at least what the path we've taken
right now is to try the carrot approach
before we you know move to something
else and i don't want to say what you're
doing is a stick but
it's it's that right now uh it's by
degrees and maybe this is the difference
between the uk right
you know versus the u.s differences it
and maybe san francisco is even
particularly this way
we did not lose people
during the start of the pandemic a lot
of different reasons we instead what we
saw was people a lot of people moved
away from san francisco
because we said you can oh yeah of
course and so i think we may have saved
ourselves from from a lot of
uh
you know departures by giving people
that escape another way
um it sounds like you already had a
distributed workforce you couldn't tell
them they could go go to other places
they already were other places right
yeah they were yeah yeah so that
wouldn't wasn't really the thing
um and we haven't said now come on back
to san francisco yet i also need to
point out another difference which i
just realized from what you said about
the difference of the cultural
differences in san francisco there's
a precedence is that the word
across every all the tech companies are
doing it following a very similar line
whereas in the uk it's not like that
so when i think about the companies
working in san francisco especially in
tech whether it's the big ones like
twitter or whatever they've all kind of
adopted the same approach so if you're
the only one not adopting that approach
i guess that's a bit of an existent a
bit of a risk
to losing people i think there's just
going to be a sorting i i agree with you
that in the start you kind of like you
followed the lead of the bigger pl we
did at least we saw what they were doing
and we followed the lead of the the
bigger players thinking that's teaching
us
um what we need to do as well i think
there'll be a sorting here it's going to
take another year or two but there will
be companies that say we're all about
hybrid work
and they'll be coming to say we're all
about office work and employees then
will say i get to sort based on which
one is the way i want to so actually
that will be a really healthy outcome
i think a lot of companies that would
never have tried the hybrid approach or
enabled remote work
are now happy they did like we are we're
happy we have this
much more
you know
geographically distributed workforce
that's bringing us incredible talent
with a lot of different experience
uh behind that
and then on the other side i
not sure you know where this is going to
go for some of the companies that are
ins like right now we're saying
you all have to come back into the
office they the
just the loose number of conversations
i've had with with other ceos says you
lose about 20 of the people if you do
that and you're not really sure which of
the 20 because it's really difficult to
know until you you
make people decide
um but they're going to be okay i mean
they'll find other people who then say
yeah i really want to work at a place
where everyone comes to the office and
that's what i want to
um and so that's the sorting that will
happen here in the next few years but
you know these things take time that's
the thing in time
you know we don't have a lot of i mean
yeah i mean we're trying to build a
long-lasting company but we want to have
we don't want this to be the thing that
gets in the way of
us progressing as a company so we are
balancing that too
is there not a middle ground where you
say like these two days a week the team
comes to the
is that a middle ground and you're just
very clear on that yeah i think that is
a really good next step uh if we're not
achieving that sense of coordination
with giving people a choice but
encouraging them to say
with incentives like lunch or or events
or uh the presence of the senior
leadership will be there on these
certain days there needs to be a point
there needs to be a point where you say
okay it's not working we're going to try
to try another way
i had a few words to say about one of my
sponsors on this podcast as the seasons
have begun to change so has my diet and
um
right now i'm going to be completely
honest with you i'm starting to think a
lot about
slimming down a little bit because over
the last couple of probably the last
four or five months my diet has been
pretty bad um and it started to show a
little bit really over the last two
months i go to the gym about 80 of the
time so i track it with 10 of my friends
in a whatsapp group and this tracker
online that we all use together
and so one of the things i'm doing now
to reduce my calorie intake and trying
to get back to being nutritionally
complete and all i eat is i'm having the
heel protein shake thank you hill for
making a product that i actually like
the salted caramel is my favorite i've
got the banana one here which is the one
my girlfriend likes but for me salted
caramel is
the one
what was the hardest moment at the start
of the strava growth
that you faced at the start in those
opening years yeah we opened like we
created
the company
got the founding team 2000 beginning of
2009
we were only web-based
so you had to you couldn't track your
workout with your mobile phone on strava
you used a
third-party gps device an example of one
was a garmin
305 cycle computer it was largely
cycling only to start with you really we
didn't encourage any other any other
sport type but you you had to have you
had to pay for that piece of equipment
you had to plug it into your
laptop or desktop computer
transfer the file and upload it
incredible friction right so we we did
not grow fast at all in the beginning it
was like so many you had to really want
to try to experience this thing you you
and it's not because mobile wasn't a
thing you could do
we just didn't do it
there were companies that started
largely with they did maybe had a
website but they pretty quickly built a
mobile app
companies like runkeeper
they were one of the first hundred apps
in the app store imagine that now there
are i don't know millions of apps in the
app store but how are run keep it doing
well they got bought i mean that's the a
lot of these companies that were we
launched into a pretty crowded space
back in 2009 there were at least 10
maybe more companies that were doing
something you would call activity
tracking with gps
most of them had a mobile app so we did
not
run keeper was acquired
in
i wanna say 2015 2014
by one of the big sports brands
map myfitness
was acquired by under armour
runtastic was acquired by adidas
by the way none of these acquirers ever
came to talk to strava
i can't tell you why i would have to
you'd have to go i
have to go talk to them
maybe we were perceived as we were too
niche
because we were perceived as only
focusing on
more hardcore athletes and not the
masses it wasn't true but
in any case what what was true back in
2009 what we had we built
you know the wrong
the wrong experience for
what ultimately would drive community
growth which is it needs to be on your
mobile phone
it needs to be
you know kind of all on your mobile
phone the mobile phone is not just the
tracking device
but then you then go to the website to
look at have the experience you need to
build the experience on mobile
and we were really late to that we were
so late
um and so by 2012 we finally have a
mobile team that's building an
experience so three years after founding
two and a half years after founding the
company
we are finally in the game if you will
how did you know you were wrong
we were wrong in the sense that we
weren't seeing the community growth we
were we were building an experience that
really people was v people once they
got through all those frictions to get
started they stuck around they were
committed they were they were engaged
they converted to the subscription which
is the core of our businesses you can
use travel for free as long as you like
but the best that we have to offer
um kind of the if you're gonna put
something you say you're gonna you're
gonna invest in yourself and try to
live a more active life you the
subscription really helps you it gives
you
more ways to stay motivated
more fun more ways to discover what's
great around you so the subscription has
all these great things and it was there
from from the early days we we didn't
wait to launch it we launched it in the
end of 2009
so we had a lot of people
who were found we had who we had a high
conversion rate if if you want we had a
low community size but a high conversion
rate so we knew we were on to something
and so what taught us we were wrong was
we we actually said okay we better build
a mobile app and
we built one that basically just tracked
your workout you could record a workout
to get it into strava
we saw off the charts community growth
in the first week really we were adding
prior to the mobile app we were adding
maybe 100 new users 100 new athletes a
week
we added
10 000 a day on the launch of the of our
mobile app we got featured in the app
store that was 100 000 in a day wow
why because it's such an easy
entry point you don't have to pay for
anything you already have the phone in
your pocket you're just downloading
um our our app from the app store the
app store is pushing you us out to
a community we would never have had the
the money to meet from a marketing
perspective
there was only one problem we built the
wrong there again we learned we built
the wrong experience we we thought you
tracked the workout on your mobile phone
and then you go to the website to see
your results and
that's uh people like
people aren't going to do that we
so we had to rebuild that that app and
that
rebuild the experience to be all
completely on mobile but the idea that
what can unlock the community growth is
the form factor of reducing the
frictions getting
meeting people where
giving them a chance to onboard into
something without having to go through a
lot of hoops jump jump through all the
things basic stuff but those those were
like the earliest things that we that we
did
did prove that we could build something
that wasn't highly engaging we just
couldn't get
people into the into the experience in
the early days until we built the mobile
apps
as you're going through that iterative
experience to figure out
how to scale the business and where the
product market fit is
how are you doing in your personal life
at that stage on the b
the balance
yeah i mean this is where going back to
when mark and i were
thinking of starting another company
we were saying it's going to be
different this time right we're not
going to let it consume us we're going
to find a way
to keep the b
in my personal case that did not
last
more than the first year i
uh we we thought we were going to build
a company i was living in hanover new
hampshire which is this very small
community in um
about two hours north of boston
in the state of new hampshire it's in
the woods um dartmouth college is there
and they had a they hired me to teach
entrepreneurship in 2000 and so that's
what brought us there my family my wife
and four kids
so we arrived when my youngest daughter
she's now 20 turning 24 this year she
was turning two that year so
you can like we had this very little you
know we have four kids in in five years
we're very young kids we're gonna raise
them in hanover and i was like we gotta
i gotta live in hanover and mark is in
in the bay area he's living in
california well he's got to live he's
got to live in in portola valley so
we're going to build this company on on
two coasts and it was going to be you
know team in new hampshire and a team in
california
and by 2010 it was like that's clearly
not going to be the case the to hire the
the talent we need
it's probably going to be the team in
san francisco that's going to be
the headquarters and so i start flying
to san francisco more and more regularly
all throughout 2010 instead of going
like once every two months i'm going
once a month staying for five days now
it's
once every two weeks staying for five
days and then it's
that's gets more and more frequent so
i'm definitely not on the on the be the
balance has gone out the window
and this was 2010 through the end almost
to the end of 2013
where i'm i'm ceo of the company we're
growing we're growing this community is
now surpassing
a million
members in the community and we get to
the point where i think we're just shy
of 10 million
by the time that i'm
stepping down and you know what uh it's
a very sad story but my wife was
diagnosed with a terminal illness in
september of 2013
she had had
been diagnosed she had had breast cancer
gone through treatment at
in 2004 long before we start started
strava and it had come back and it was
uh it was
you know those those first months we
weren't sure exactly how long she
she would have to live the doctors were
we got to do a lot of tests and
um
i'm
i'm still living this dual life between
new hampshire and california because she
didn't move to california with me we
didn't move the family that was a choice
we made to remain in new hampshire
um as the home base for the family
and so what ends up happening at the end
of 2013 is
i stepped down from running the company
mark steps in as the ceo
i
i'm in a supportive function but i have
a lot of flexibility and i move back to
new hampshire
and
for the next
three and a half years until anna passed
away i
that was my
my priority became
taking care of my family taking doing
what i could to
to take what time we had left to make it
as meaningful as possible and all sorts
of things we can talk about of finding
meaning to the
to the last day there's there's a lot of
lessons learned there but
what i was
that's not that's a different kind of
balance
i want to be honest it's like
not necessarily what i what i expect you
know when we say balance for as a value
it it feels like what we do is we pass
through that balance point
over and over again in our lives
we never quite seize it and hold on to
it
and feel like we live in it but it's
something we experience we go through
over and over again
and we try to return to it and it's the
act of trying to return to it
that i hold out as like that's what i'm
motivated by by putting balance into the
core values of strava by having it be
something i focus on in my life
i want to return to it as often as i can
even if i won't be able to stay in it
all the time
so leaving strava that was the that was
definitely not balance
moving into
caring for my family there were periods
where it came in
definitely found a
flow and a harmony and a balance but
then times where you know just it
completely is out the window and
everything is all hands on deck on
what's the next treatment we're going to
try to find for
for anna where are we going to in one
case we had to move
and we chose to move back to move to san
francisco so she could be in a clinical
trial
of a novel therapy that showed some
promise and these are the kinds of
examples where balance just didn't
wasn't there either you you had to you
had to work at it and then
in the balance is where i think you find
the most meaningful moments
you said about the passing of your wife
anna in that period you were trying to
find meaning to the last day
and you've learned a lot about
what that is
what is that
you have to you have to think of it not
as the
goal is to get to something
some state of health or physical ability
or mental ability
to do something
like a dream or a
trip you want to take
it's
it's the the day that is the day you're
you're living in it's take it as it
comes
today and
having having a living a life where
we're all terminal by the way turns out
we're all on our way to some point where
we say we're on our last day
but what you experience when you're
going through regular measurement of the
progress of a disease like that
because that's the way your your the
medical
treatment is we're monitoring the
disease to know
when to change therapy
when to add other drugs that will help
handle the
side effects of all the therapy
when to say it's time to stop the
therapy
the meaning can't be
extend my life
at some point
if that's your goal you will not find
meaning in that goal it will be out the
window
so you instead you have to find meaning
in what can this day bring
it starts by
how do i feel today
um
if you string together a bunch of days
where you feel
you've gotten something out of the day
that's a meaningful life and you can
find that to the very end and
just i learned
so much from watching anna progress
through that
and uh give
give to people around her but also give
to herself she was an artist
worked in her studio
to nearly the very last day
was working on projects that she knew
she would never finish but she was
motivated by what she could
experience
of working on those pieces of art she
did leave behind like
if
if this were going to continue here's
what i would do with it
my youngest is an artist i know what's
motivating her is like she wants to get
to some of those
pieces and see if she can bring them to
some version of what her mom
had left behind what what she had
indicated this could be something like
this
i think mira will bring it to something
else she'll add her own thing to it but
that that was what on a
you know i think she got there
struggling against the end is not the
way to find the meaning
how has that shifted your because
experiences like that i imagine um
teach you other profound things about
the point of all of this
i know i spent much of my early years
thinking the point of all of this was to
buy a lamborghini right and then even
the pandemic was one of the catalysts
that made me realize there was
as i said earlier this tectonic plate
that mattered a little bit more and then
it was really interesting to watch um
how i had a rolex at the time i don't
have one anymore but my rolex was
exchanged for my apple watch and there's
something quite symbolic in that it went
from being about
signaling status to others to
caring about my health
and when i think about
the loss of someone um especially
someone
young
someone close to you as well what are
the what is the priority shift that
happens
you know i'm presuming there is one but
is there a priority shift that happens a
different perspective on what matters
that maybe an entrepreneur like me needs
to hear
i don't i don't know that i
knew this
when she was going through her life
those last few years or
even the
few years after she passed away i don't
think i was
i was i think i prepared a lot for how
to live my life caring for her i wasn't
prepared for how to live my life when
she was gone
but what i've come to
i think is
it's this is again maybe
somewhat obvious
is that
the relationship
you can build with some an individual
and in this case my wife the person i we
met
where did we meet in your
we met in my backyard
when i
when i started grad school at
northwestern university
i rented this coach house which is like
a little carriage house behind a
bigger home and i was walking to the
front of the house one morning
to get my mail
and walking through the backyard and
there's this
young woman in her pajamas talking to my
landlord and
this is anna she's she turns turns out
she's a friend of my landlord had
babysit sat for her children when she
was going to
college at the same school i was getting
my phd this is northwestern university
in chicago in evanston illinois
so i meet ana and in my backyard and
she's not living in evanston she's
living in cincinnati ohio
but she she comes back to visit a few
months later
and a few months after that we're
married
and so
we start we're we're babies right i'm i
got married the day after i turned 25. i
remember she was 23.
we were not yet fully formed
human beings right we're but we're now
building a life together
and
we went through all sorts of
highs and lows in our marriage and
we had the we have four children and we
we live
otherwise
like this life we would say we built
something together i look back on that
and say like the best thing i've built
it's two things my friendship with mark
and my marriage with anna
those
i hope those are those are the things i
look back on
apart from everything else and say
at the end when when my day comes
like those were the things where meaning
comes from
that's where
if i go back to what's most important
it's the relationships with the people
who are closest to you in your life
and then that extends to the people who
are also important but they may not you
may not have that same bond
so what did i learn
well losing that person
is extremely difficult you're left with
i was i don't want to speak for everyone
who goes through this but it's there is
an aspect of you don't know
which way is up anymore you're off
script you're
whatever you thought your life was going
to be about it is you you're questioning
everything
and
um
in my case i had four children
who were 17 to
22 at a in age at that time
and
we
pulled together
this is
i wear this bracelet this is i gave one
to each of my children i they wear it
every day we get we this is on the day
of anna's
funeral
and
we pulled together and we helped each
other through that darkest darkest
moment
and again it's the relationships
and it's
we we're a normal family we've got our
highs and lows um
we got we got dysfunction we got
function you know it's we've got it all
but there's something in there that's
like we know what we can that we can
count on each other we know that with
that that is at the core
i want to i want to look at that as like
the model for what is possible even
inside something like a company
even in something like the strava
community that that's happening that
people are building relationships
so
if strava is like what is it all about
it's about motivating people to be
active through the relationships they
build with other people
and you return to the
company several years after anna passed
that that section between anna passing
and your return to the company you you
almost referenced being somewhat
disorientated in terms of not knowing
were you were you double guessing
whether to go back to the company
i wasn't thinking of going back um no i
wasn't we had recruited in
someone to replace mark as ceo uh so
mark stepped down in may of 2017 so just
a few months after anna passed away
i wasn't thinking about returning at all
i was you know i was that was
a i knew i had to discover what was next
but i wasn't considering that it was
going to be returning to strava so what
got
me closer was that strava started to
need some help um
by 2018 i step in as interim cfo and
head of people
um
by the middle of 2019 we're looking at
a pretty challenging environment for the
company we were
um
[Music]
we were about 100 and 200 people in
terms of team size we were not
profitable
um
and we had to figure out a way to get to
sustainability very quickly we were
not able to
raise capital at that time given the
state of the business and so
we made a decision to make a leadership
change
and
i
would i recall from the conversations
with the board
i want to characterize it as like i feel
like i was the least bad of all the bad
options because there weren't very many
good options at that time we weren't
going to be able to recruit someone in
given the state of
the company i don't know if i was ready
to
dive back in this is i'm still really
doubting whether what my place is right
now
but there was one thing that mark and i
were convinced about which was inside
what we had what was there there was a
great company
we had
at that time
50 million people in the community so 50
million registered athletes
we were not yet profitable but we what
we
november 2nd 2019 my second day back
leading the company
we get up on stage and we say here's
here's the path back this is how we're
going to do this
we're going to focus
nearly 100 of this company on our
customer and that's the person who wants
to lead an active life that's the
athlete
we're going to build this for them
and we're going to we're going to build
something so good that they're going to
pay for it and that's the subscription
so
we focused the company on that goal to
build the best subscription service for
the athlete
and the team responded
they dug in we climbed that mountain
and
we did have help with pandemic bringing
us a lot more people we doubled during
the pandemic from 50 million to i think
we're now we're at 99 million registered
athletes
so we have we
the uh the team knows i love analogies
we had the right sails up when the wind
started to blow we got that tailwind
from the pandemic and it accelerated our
business
and so now we can imagine a very
different outcome as a result
uh for this company we were 2019
it was how do we get this back on track
now it's how do we make the most of this
opportunity
and for me personally
i've had to really rethink
everything from
what's my purpose what what what
motivates me to be the person who can
lead this company
and what i'm reconnecting with is this
is what we intended all along is that
mark and i create something
that we want to stick with and stay with
for decades
so finding that path back personally out
of the abyss that i was in is tied
integrally to
what strava means for that future for me
i
you know i
don't at all ascribe to the idea that i
saved strava but strava saved me
brought me back from something
and
where we have now what we have to look
forward to what we can be what we can
imagine for the future of the company
and the community we're building for is
a much much richer experience doing more
for athletes all the time
investing in
what they're like they'll be able to
experience years from now
how it will be a part of their active
life for as long as they live
because we've built sustainability into
the core of the business
yeah so one of the really difficult
things
in 2019 when you're changing the
fundamental model of a business
under the pressure of
a cash crunch as they call it when cash
is running out because you're not
comfortable and you can't raise
is
you've got to let some people go
and it sometimes feels like a bit of a
contradiction of values that when you're
a family
you know you have that kind of family
community connection you really care
about the people but then there's got to
be a decision at some point to
say goodbye to some of them
unvoluntarily and
for the greater interest of the company
you you had to do that right in 2019
yeah that was november 1st so november
2nd was how we're going to get this
company back
to winning again november 1st was we
have to let in that time it was a little
over i think 32 people go out of
out of the 200 or so that were there
so
[Music]
uh
really tough way for your first day back
on the job
but what was even harder was that the
deep wound
it created in that family that sense of
we didn't think this would happen here
how come we didn't know
that feeling of
can i trust
leadership and they didn't know me i
wasn't i wasn't like i was a host i was
not around
nearly
for for most of the people in the
company at that time they weren't hired
during the time when i was the ceo the
first time
they knew that i was a founder they knew
i had been helping out as an interim cfo
but i wasn't really a presence
for in in leadership for them
so
there was just the basic level of
needing to rebuild trust needing to say
not only do we have a plan but you're
you're a really important part of the
plan
and here's how i show
that you can trust me or here's how i
want to build a relationship so that
over time you will trust me
that period of time in november and
december and january
i remember i think just the the level of
how
much we thought about every word we said
was aimed
at the objective of getting people to
believe again
compared to today
where i think people believe
and maybe what we're changing what we
focus on now is getting them to
understand what our potential is
they believe that we are going to be
successful but
i think we today where i focus so much
my effort is
making sure people connect with what our
what our potential really is and how
we're going to get there
whereas in in 2019 it was all about
believing we even had one a future
today your the company looks very
different from in some respects to the
company that you and mark set out to
build there's now hundreds of people
when you started out you wanted 20 or 30
in this company you weren't going to do
what you did last time
yeah um and we do talk about that it's
like this is very different than what we
had imagined you know something that was
additive to it's additive in a very
different way
but something that where we could
by and large
not give up so much of
our personal life for the sake of
the company that what we're creating
and
you know
it is consuming and that so
what part of that is well this is what
we should have expected if we were going
to be successful it's just a given you
have to do it this way
and what part is it you need to create
the structure so you can
maintain that measure of
i'm still michael horvath apart from
strava strava is not my 100 of my
identity
that's something i struggle with
and it's really important because
i don't think i'll be as good a leader
if my identity is completely wrapped up
in this company i need to have
that level of commitment that says i'm
here this is super important to me but i
have to be myself
i cannot be
define myself as this is the thing that
makes me who i am what's the risk
well for someone who's a rather
emotional person you'll bring your
emotion to the decision in a in an
unhealthy way if your identity is
wrapped up in the company
so what i strive for
is thinking what is in the best interest
of strava
and ever like when i wake up in the
morning i ask myself the question what
am i doing today
to help connect people to the full
potential of what we can create
and that sometimes is it's the obvious
things making sure that we're we have
the right set of priorities
executing against a longer term strategy
not
um
churning people around with different
ideas
limiting how many things i throw into
the room
some days it's about do we have the
right team do we have to add someone or
take someone away from the team
those are hard choices for someone who's
pretty
i call it emote i say emotional i have a
lot of feeling
and so
that's the part that i feel like i
suppress a lot is like i can't feel as
much
i can't let myself feel everything i
want to feel
because i feel it will come out in ways
that are not healthy not in the best
interest of the company
so
what gets me through that is like well
that's not this is me as the ceo of this
company it's not me michael horvath
that's another person who will live on
i'm not going to be the ceo forever
so i will have a life that's my life and
what is that life what is in that life
that is mine that isn't the companies
um one thing is for example everyone in
the company knows this i love to cook
it's it's i feel like it's an incredibly
valuable
creative outlet i'd love to cook for
other people
there's nothing more better than to
imagine a meal
design it think of it think it through
get all the ingredients make the dinner
and have your friends or your family
sitting around a table
and enjoying what you've created that
for me that is
that is part of my identity
and so finding like that's that's that's
a core belief in
if you you got to give some time for
that you got to you got to invest in
that you you you
create the space for it as a way to say
it still there's still a part of me
that's not the company
has that specific issue of identity
evolved or changed in you since anna
passed
yeah um
that's a really really
interesting and like that the way i
think about it is
i had to
not rediscover who i am i had to define
who i am after my life with her i was
dramatically changed by my life with her
i don't go back to being the person i
was without her
i am somebody who is now discovering who
am i as
the survivor of that life with her
that doesn't happen overnight
i think my
first
inclination was to try to make it happen
as quickly as possible
get on with it
find find out who you are and i think
well at least what i learned was you
you can make some pretty
what you think are good choices or good
moves and you realize it's not
that's not you that's not the what you
you're you're still
thinking of the life you had and wanting
to recreate find fill the hole that's
missing you know the deep wound you're
trying to sort of
fill that with something
when
there's something yet to be discovered
about what you really who you really are
on the other side of this
so as i said i wasn't thinking
at all of going back to
strava joining you know coming back to
the company i wasn't thinking of
starting another company
i didn't know what it was going to be i
imagine it was going to be something
like
uh
deep sense of rescuing people somewhere
like this idea that
what i couldn't save
my wife but i'm gonna go find other
people to save
but that isn't it that was just that
that again was like this idea that i'm
trying to solve
the hole in my heart
by finding people i can
help
and what i've
though it wasn't that what i chose or
how i thought i would get
that sense of purpose again that sense
of who i am
it is through strava it is through
running this company and connecting back
to what we tried to create the idea we
had in 1995 the thing we came back to in
2006 the way in which we've built this
team around our
abc's
with the future we can have
the the company that we will be in 20
and 30 years i can contribute something
to that now and that's what is
that is
where where i have found that sense of
completeness again
so we have a closing tradition on this
podcast which is the previous guest
writes a question for the next guest so
so clever okay
what should the average person optimize
their life for if their goal is
fulfillment
said another way
how is fulfillment achieved
i believe we are
what we do every day
and what i mean by that is that it's not
the big moments
it's not the
thing we strive for for
several years and achieve at one moment
in time or the big trip we take or
call it the peaks
that actually give us the most meaning
they are important
but what really defines who we are is
what we do
every day
and so if what you do every day
is put a little effort into being active
being kind to the people who are
important to you in your life and the
complete strangers
if that's how you walk through life
then that's where you're going to find
the meaning
so
fulfillment i believe comes from
being intentional about what we do
every day
amen and you this to you you said it
correctly you said that you don't
realize that you then you then have that
impact on others well i've have a
podcast and tens of millions of people
downloaded and i bang on about
the fact that i changed yeah and what
that does for people who are struggling
like i used to struggle
with all these false starts in their
fitness journey is it lets them know
that it is also possible for today to be
the day where you where you begin that
journey in your life and again if you
think about the catalyst there that that
strata moment at the start of my journey
and how many tens of millions of people
have now heard me talk about this um
it's incredible the the ripple effect
across the ocean by one small catalyst
so
thank you
thank you
as you might know crafted are one of the
sponsors of this podcast and crafted are
a jewelry brand and they make really
meaningful pieces of jewellery and this
piece by crafted when i put it on for me
it represents courage it represents
ambition it represents being calm and
loving and respectful and nurturing
while also being the antithesis of that
seemingly the antithesis of that which
is um sometimes a little bit aggressive
with my goals and determined and
courageous and brave the really
wonderful thing about crafted jewelry is
it's super affordable it looks amazing
the pieces hold tremendous meaning and
they are really well made
[Music]
oh
[Music]
you